خلف هذا الباب، نتوقع أن
نجد ديميتري سي تي آي، أحد رؤساء فوجنر
في جمهورية أفريقيا الوسطى،
ممنوع منعا باتا الوصول إلى جميع الأشخاص الذين
لا يعملون هنا. يحذرنا من طرقنا
دون إجابة وبعد فترة وجيزة طُلب منا
مغادرة المبنى عدنا  إلى قلب
إمبراطورية يني بران في أفريقيا لنرى كيف
غيّرت وفاته الأمور ووجد أن
اثنين من مساعديه ما زالا يديران
العرض فالي بيرف هو المسؤول عن
القطعة الأمنية بينما تدير CTI
الجانب التجاري، يحب C أن يبقى بعيدًا عن
الأنظار.  أيام وهذا ليس
مفاجئًا نظرًا لأنه نجا من
هجوم بقنبلة بريدية هنا في ديسمبر
2022 بعد الهجوم، بدأ السكان المحليون في
ارتداء قمصان لدعمه، وهي علامة
على شعبية فوجنر الراسخة هنا،
التقينا بـ CTI لأول مرة في عام
2019 رسميًا، وكان يتصرف كممثل.
مترجم لكن الوثائق أظهرت أنه كان
رئيسًا لشركة مملوكة لشركة Vagner المنحلة
تدعى luai Invest وأنه
بدأ العمل مع progan للتأثير على
الانتخابات الأمريكية في ما يسمى بـ
troll Factory في عام
2016 وتلقى تعليمه في باريس ويتقن اللغتين
الفرنسية والإنجليزية والإسبانية  أنشأ C لاحقًا
المركز الثقافي الروسي في
بونجي والذي استثمرت فيه مجموعة
القرن، كما يقول فاجنر، الذي يستخدمه كواجهة
لبيع الذهب والماس لكبار الشخصيات
وإدارة عمليات الأخشاب والكحول،
ويعد المركز واحدًا من آخر الأماكن
التي تم تصوير بران فيها بشكل حي هنا
مع وقوف C إلى جانبه، قمنا بالتصوير
سرًا في المركز الثقافي حيث أخبرتنا
امرأة أطلقت على نفسها اسم نفيسة كيروفا
أن وفاة بران لم
تغير الوضع
الراهن، لذلك
يستمر البيت الثقافي الروسي على ما هو عليه، وبالتالي
لا يحصل ديميتري على هذه الوظيفة  بعد الآن، لماذا لم يعد
مسؤولاً عن المهمة بأكملها،
لذا فهو يريد هذه الوظيفة، فهو يدير
اتجاهًا آخر الآن حسنًا حسنًا حسنًا، لذلك
كلهم ​​نفس الأشخاص في الأساس، نعم
حسنًا، في مقابلة نادرة وحديثة مع
وسائل الإعلام الروسية، يقول C إنه يأمل في
المهمة  لن
يتغير إذا بدأنا في التراجع،
فكل ما تم بناؤه سوف
ينهار أيضًا، هذه هي فرصتنا، فنحن
نبحث الآن عن أصدقاء جدد شركاء
أسواق جديدة أفريقيا فرصة
لروسيا خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع، ظهر مقطع فيديو
لاحتفال لإحياء ذكرى الوفاة  من
أفضل أصدقاء بران بران لسكان وسط
أفريقيا، هناك لافتة مكتوب عليها بينما
ينظر رئيس الأمن في فاجنر، فيتالي بيريل،
بعد شهر واحد من وفاته، ولا يزال مساعدو بران
واقفين يراقبون إمبراطوريته
[موسيقى]